[Musik]
gedenken an alexander der 20 jahre alte
student und aushilfs kassierer der
tankstelle ist erschossen worden nur
weil er seine pflicht erfüllte zur
vorsicht mahnte zum schutz vor dem
corona virus rückblick der achtzehnte
september kurz vor acht täter mario m
geht in den tankstellenshop um bier zu
holen aber ohne mund nasen maske
aushilfs kassierer alexander weigert
sich ihn zu bedienen die männer geraten
den streit danach geht der aggressive
kunde wieder knapp zwei stunden später
kehrt der 49 jährige zurück was dann
passiert schildert die
tankstellenpächterin
wir haben das auch videos ansehen müssen
und es war einfach eine kaltblütige tat
dieses täters der sich in der reihe
anstellt und als er dann an der kasse
ankommt provokativ die maske runterzieht
was willst du jetzt tun und das sieht
man halt von hinten die gestik unseres
kassierers der dann sagt scheinbar
ziehen sie die maske bitte hoch er war
immer sehr freundlich sehr höflich
daraufhin wurde ihm direkt ohne zu
zögern in den kopf geschossen doch wie
ist mario m zum mörder geworden hier ist
sein zuhause in dieser wohnsiedlung in
idar oberstein hier hat mario auch
seinen firmensitz zwölf jahre arbeitete
er selbstständig als software entwickler
laut seiner internetseite auch für dax
konzerne dort klagt mario m über die
pandemie so habe der lockdown auch
negativen einfluss auf unsere
auftragslage
auf twitter folgt der unter anderem bion
röcke rechtsaußen der afd unter
pseudonym vorsicht an der bahnsteigkante
verrät der todesschütze schon vor
corinna rechtsextreme gesinnung und
gewaltfantasien
er warnt vor einer globalen
machtergreifung der antifaschisten
postet ich freue mich auf den nächsten
krieg schreibt mir geht heutzutage viel
zu oft das messer auf bald sich die
faust die politologin katharina kuhn hat
sich mit dem täterprofil in den sozialen
medien befasst hier spricht dafür dass
der täter sich im umfeld eben von
radikalen verschwörung center logan
bewegt hat die verschwörungs erzählungen
zu corona verbreiten teils davon
gesprochen dass er selbst sich für einen
rassisten helgo als rassist bekennt und
von da muss man sagen da fand eine
radikalisierung wahrscheinlich nicht von
heute auf morgen statt im herbst 2009 10
drohte mario m öffentlich sein motiv
hass auf den staat meine muskeln sind
gespannt mein geist geschärft gnade
denen welche diese situation
heraufbeschworen haben in der siedlung
war mario n als aufgebrachter corona
leugner bekannt bestätigt nachbarin pia
knopp von 300.000 toten habe er
schwadroniert sei leicht reizbar
impulsiv gewesen er war aggressiv
unberechenbar provokant beziehungsweise
er hat sich durch alles provoziert
gefühlt alles mögliche und nichtigkeiten
und
kurze zündschnur tickende zeitbombe ich
habe diesen menschen nur völlig
durchgeknallt erlebt im frühjahr 2020
eskaliert bei den eltern von mario in
ein streit sein vater ein waffennarr mit
illegalem arsenal schießt mit einem
revolver seiner ehefrau ins gesicht und
tötet sich anschließend selbst mario 1
mutter überlebt schwer verletzt die
nachbarn bekommen angst ich hab ihm da
schon alles zugetraut und als ich
mitbekommen habe dass er da ist ein
vater mit dieser aktion
da dachte ich mir na ja toll jetzt
kannst du davon ausgehen
jetzt machst du jeden tag hier sowieso
eine gratwanderung wenn er die waffen
vorhatte
vier tage nach der tat äußert sich der
sprecher des innenministers zum stand
der ermittlungen nach allen
erkenntnissen die wir bisher haben
handelt es sich um einen einzelfall von
dem wir nun keine
generalisierende rückschlüsse ziehen
können
keine generalisierende rückschlüsse
solche erklärungen reichen dem
rechtsextremismus forscher miro dietrich
nicht
ich kann erst gesagt dieses von
einzelfall nicht mehr hören wir hatten
das bei so vielen sachen mittlerweile
wie wir gesehen haben gab es davor sehr
viele der gewaltsame
auseinandersetzungen masken regulierung
es gab danach sehr viele nachahmer die
davon geredet haben archiv konstant kann
ich dich auch erschießen und es gab
online ja eine sehr große szene die
diese tat auch gefeiert hat und die
diesen täter verlief also finde ich
schon etwas schwach hier von einem
einzelfall zu reden die tat kommt nicht
aus dem nichts und das wird nicht die
letzte bleiben
corona demos überall in deutschland die
meisten friedlich die zahl der
protestierenden wird zwar kleiner noch
der verfassungsschutz warnt vor
zunehmender radikalisierung der szene
vor allem durch rechtsradikale corona
leugnung im ersten pandemie jahr stiegen
die straftaten bei volksverhetzung und
beleidigung von 5.000 67 auf
hinzu kommen immer mehr gewalttaten von
corona leugnen der brandanschlag auf das
robert-koch-institut ein brandanschlag
auf das rathaus in delmenhorst und mehr
als 190 brandanschläge auf impfzentren
bundesweit erst jetzt hat der
verfassungsschutz reagiert damit er
radikale corona leute noch besser in den
blick bekommt hat die behörde die neue
prüf kategorie delegitimierung des
staates geschaffen drahtzieher sollen so
besser beobachtet werden vor allem im
netz
dass es so lange gedauert hat dass diese
personen auch beobachtet werden und wenn
er jetzt eine eigene kategorie geschafft
hat zeigt ja wie sehr der
verfassungsschutz digitale entwicklungen
verschlafen hat im internet macht eine
neue partei offensiv front gegen korona
maßnahmen der bundesregierung und masken
pflicht ein wahlwerbespot der partei die
basis
ein kind mit maske begleitetem not eine
seniorin wird mit gewalt zum corona
abstrich gezwungen in ihrem
bundestagswahlprogramm
lehnt die basis corona schutzmaßnahmen
ab rund 650.000 zweitstimmen hat die
querdenker partei erhalten deshalb kann
sie jetzt mit erheblicher
wahlkampfkostenerstattung rechnen
die partei die basis ist definitiv ein
sammelbecken für unterschiedlichste
verschwörungs ideologische gruppierungen
und wir haben da eben auch an
kandidierende
die sehr radikale verschwörungs
erzählung verbreitet haben ich sehe das
als großes problem dass die partei eben
aufgrund der wahlergebnisse jetzt in die
parteienfinanzierung rutschen wird das
heißt diese partei mit geldern
ausgestattet in höhe von mehreren
hunderttausend euro die natürlich wieder
in die verbreitung von
verschwörungstheorien investiert werden
können der verfassungsschutz hat
angekündigt radikale querdenker werden
bundesweit beobachtet
auf konkrete fragen dazu beantwortet die
sicherheitsbehörde nicht verweist auf
eine stellungnahme des präsidenten kurz
vor der tat von idar oberstein da sagt
thomas haldenwang wenn sich die
gewaltspirale so weiter dreht würde ich
nicht ausschließen dass sie auch tödlich
enden kann
das ist eine sehr große
ich denke das haben wir auch nach der
tat gesehen dass es ja durchaus mehrere
leute gab die nebentäter darüber
gejubelt haben die dem auch zugestimmt
haben dass das etwas richtiges wäre und
gerade auf telegramm hat sich einfach
eine große welt etabliert die in so
einem kollektiven wahn gefangen ist in
dem seine verteidigungsreaktion aus
ihrer perspektive total gerechtfertigt
wäre am tatort in idar oberstein blumen
trotz der trauer um alexander ist die
tankstelle pilgerstätte für
gewaltbereite pandemie leugner geworden
da gab es jetzt einige kunden die uns
seither aufgesucht haben die ohne maske
den laden betreten haben so richtig
provokant was es echt wieder finde ich
total widerlich da gab es letzte woche
einen drohanruf im abend bereich als ein
mitarbeiter sich gemeldet hat wollte er
wurde ihm gesagt dass jetzt seid ihr
dran und ich schieß eine kugel in den
kopf